what would be the point of all the pain
and sacrifice
if i wasn't willing to stand up and keep
fighting
show a lot of things happening at once
remind
everyone of what's going on gonna need a
montage
a sports training montage
after last week's smashing finale we
have the penultimate episode of the
falcon in the winter soldier
called truth and truth be told it's
pretty good setting up a crazy finale
which might see a new falcon
new captain america and lots of insane
reveals
so in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the episode looking at what
could be in that wakandan briefcase
what the future has in store for zemo
and of course
that jld cameo this video does contain
some serious sleuthing so if you're not
wanting to be spoiled on what might
happen next episode
just turn down the volume and put on a
blindfold and let it play so i can get
that sweet sweet watch time now make
sure to like and subscribe
because here we go and what better
encapsulates this new cap oh god these
puns are getting worse
than running away from his problems
picking up right after the events of
episode 4
john walker has hidden himself away in
an abandoned factory
haunted by the death of his partner
lamar and the violent act he just
committed it makes sense this happens in
a factory since he
is basically a manufactured hero bucky
and falcon
who witnessed jon's savage attack want
the shield
back you gotta give me the shield man
but cap isn't having it and in a brawl
resembling that of a wwe match
the three fight with jon almost killing
falcon the same way he killed nico
we can see just how unhinged he is here
but bucky and sam working together are
able to disarm him
literally breaking his arm in the
process bucky tosses the bloody shield
to sam
sam has rejected it throughout the
entirety of the season but it's in this
episode he learns to
embrace it and take on the mantle
meanwhile the grc is conducting raids in
their search for carly morgenthau who
two episodes ago blew up one of their
supply depots killing 11
people joaquin taurus tells sam that
finding carly will be difficult
she has people all over the world
helping her and when joaquin tells sam
he forgot his wings which were ripped
off by jon in their fight
sam says to keep them if you're thinking
what i'm thinking they
are setting up joaquin to be the new
falcon since sam will become the new
captain america the name joaquin even
dates back further than spanish to
hebrew meaning
lifted by god taurus taking up the wings
may mean we see him taking on batroc
while bucky takes on carly and sam takes
on evil cap
sam's whole journey this season has been
about coming to terms with who he is and
whether or not he'll take up the mantle
of
captain america in this episode we see
him acquire
a briefcase given to him by the
wakandans via bucky most likely this is
a
new pair of wings and or suit made with
vibranium
so he'll be able to take on the super
soldier that is john walker who
in the promo material we see strolling
the streets of new york with his new
shield sam becoming this new cap has
been hinted at in leaked pictures of the
new toy line
notice how jon puts his middle of honor
on the shield it's unclear whether if he
actually made it a part of his shield
but the promo image here
suggests he didn't we've seen how the
editors have changed certain shots of
falcon in the winter soldier like in
this promo material released months ago
which showed the sokovian memorial quite
different than how we see it in episode
5.
jon is stripped of his rank and given in
other than honorable discharge which he
deems unfair after all you built me
and his wife who we haven't seen since
episode 2 has already started to plan
out how to repair his image you start by
visiting lamar's parents
everyone in john's life even his wife
have molded him into an
image of what he should be an image
almost no person can possibly live
up to enter contessa valentina allegra
de fontaine
played by none other than julia louise
dreyfus she was actually scheduled to
appear first in black widow but that was
pushed back due to covid could she
possibly come from the same soviet
training program as natasha romanov and
yelena bolova in the comics she's a
triple asian
first working as a sleeper agent for
leviathan the soviet espionage agency
second she joins shield and third
infiltrates hydra taking up the identity
of madame
hydra in the comics she's depicted as
having a white streak through her hair
but here
it's purple the same color as her jacket
and boots
purple was heavily used by zemo so i'm
wondering if there's a connection there
even though
zemo despised hydra it's also said she
had a love affair with nick fury
and her handing out business cards is
just like nick trying to assemble a crew
could she be assembling a new crew of
villains
possibly the thunderbolts who in the
comics were initially conceived by
surprise surprise baron zemo later in
the episode we see zemo being taken away
to the raft by the wakandans the raft
being the special underwater prison
which sam actually spent time
during captain america civil war
something tells me this isn't the last
we'll see of zemo
but going back to that scene we see how
bucky has changed making amends with
zemo deciding not to kill him even after
all the [ __ ] zemo made bucky do
as the winter soldier bucky's internal
journey is far from over
in his talk with sam we learn that bucky
has been going about making amends
all the wrong way this exercise is not
about making himself feel better
it's about making others and he can do
this by giving them closure and who do
we know who needs closure
of course it's mr nakajima who doesn't
know that bucky killed his son when he
was the winter soldier
expect that next episode back in
baltimore sam visits isaiah but before
we do
we get a glimpse of isaiah's grandson
eli who if you haven't seen my episode 2
breakdown
later becomes the superhero patriot a
member of the young avengers
sam learns more about isaiah's past how
he was used as a test subject
a prisoner unable to see his wife and
later discarded like a piece of trash
it's no wonder he says those stars in
stripe stone
mean nothing good to me for isaiah the
shield is a representation of all the
bad america has done to him and
african americans in general he even
says no self-respecting black man would
ever want to be
captain america this all ties into sam's
speech in episode 1 where he says
symbols are only as good as the men and
women behind them
in the past we've seen steve rogers a
beacon of hope and justice while
john walker one of injustice if sam does
end up taking up the mantle
he will become a new symbol one which
can help heal the injustices of the past
there's no better metaphor for this
healing than sam and sarah's boat sam
has continually said they can't get rid
of this broken down thing because it's a
part of their history
they just can't erase it like isaiah's
past was erased
but they can refurbish it make it better
heal it
the ship is a metaphor for the healing
of america
after a little flirting between bucky
and sarah and of course a heineken
product placement
bucky agrees to stay with sam for a bit
we get these great little moments of
sam's nephews playing with this shield
really showing that even after
what the new cap did steve's legacy
hasn't been tarnished the new camp
consoles lamar's family and later sees a
poster of
cap is back all this fueling him to
later go rogue and construct his own
suit and shield
in our only scene featuring sharon she's
on the phone with someone speaking
french
the subtitles confirm this is georges
batroc who we saw in episode 1
and who we'll later see working with the
flag smashers i still think sharon is
the power broker and we know the
power broker wants carly for her super
soldier blood after the vials were
destroyed in episode 4.
my guess is that betruck will end up
double-crossing carly and the flag
smashers somehow
in the promo material we do see sharon
showing up in a parking garage with red
lights in the background
red lights which we saw go off at the
grc meeting could she have finally made
it back to new york after she said she
couldn't travel out of madrapore fearing
extradition
it's interesting the scene begins on
theodore jericho's 1819 painting the
raft of the medusa the director
purposely focusing on a black man at the
center of the frame
the painting itself shows the stranded
crew of the menusa trying to flag down a
rescue ship
i'll let you decide what the director
was trying to say here
the scene ends on monet's impressionist
painting woman with a parasol
impressionism was given its name by a
french art critic who said the paintings
weren't complete and rather just
impressions or sketches of the finished
product perhaps we are only getting an
impression of who sharon really is
something to be revealed in the final
episode she
is that woman in the parasol sam and
bucky have come a long way since
partnering up in episode 2. they've
become good friends even if neither has
said it
outright they talk again about sam not
taking up the shield as he literally
takes up the shield the legacy of that
shield
is complicated to say the least
just like the history of america is
complicated bucky says the shield was
the closest thing he had to family and
by sam giving it away
he had nothing left i think bucky will
soon learn that sam will become
something like a second family to him
out in public but truck does the
stupidest thing and opens a briefcase
full of weapons
dova cheer is not impressed with carly's
plan
so we're working with criminals now
remember he didn't know about carly's
plan to blow up the supply depot
i wouldn't be surprised if carly goes
too far in her plan that dovich ends up
switching sides
or stopping her in some way especially
if patruck turns out to double cross
them carly's plan involves stopping the
grc from voting on the patch act an act
which would see
20 million refugees returned back to
their countries of origin
remember that the flag's masters believe
in a unified world with no borders
one word one people one word one people
this guy who gets a message on his phone
because he's loyal to the flag's masters
looks like it could be the same security
guard who locks the grc
in and says one world one people near
the end of the episode in one of the
promo videos we see the delegates
attacked by what appears to be gas
taurus alerts sam to recent flagsmaster
activity in new york hinting that's
where the next strike will take place
so it looks like next episode is
culminating in this massive attack in
new york with
all our players sam bucky evil cap
sharon and the flag smashers
battling it out i think we'll see sam
and bucky victorious however it will
likely set up something
much larger for the mcu you don't have a
huge star like julia louise dreyfus in
for just one scene in one show without
her being promised a much larger role in
the
mcu but to find out how exactly she fits
into all this we'll just have to wait
until
next episode thanks for watching
everyone please make sure to give the
video a like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much